- Hi, everyone,
welcome to Homeroom with Sal.
We have a very exciting conversation
and I also have two
temporary co-hosts today
because our guest is a
bit of a hero for them.
We have a bit of a chess household.
So we're going to have hopefully
a very engaging conversation
with Magnus Carlsen,
World Chess Champion,
highest rated chess player
about all things chess and life
and getting better at things
that might seem hard at first.
But before we jump into that conversation
I will give my standard announcements.
First of all,
reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit.
We can only exist through
philanthropic donations.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate.
Also want to give a special shout out
to a whole series of organizations
that really helped step up
when it was clear that
the world was depending
on Khan Academy, more than
ever during the pandemic
and we were running at a deficit.
So special thanks to Bank of
America, AT&T, Google.org,
Novartis, Fastly and General Motors,
and our many other
supporters of all levels,
hundreds of thousands of folks
who donate whatever they can
to make Khan Academy a possibility.
Also want to remind everyone
that there is a podcast
version of this live stream
wherever you get your podcasts,
Homeroom with Sal The Podcast.
So with that, I'm excited
to introduce Magnus,
World Chess Champion.
Magnus, great to have you here.
- Thank you so much.
Great to be here.
- And this is a very special occasion.
We've never had quite this
many co-hosts on the session.
It's because of you.
We're getting so many questions
that are coming in over
social media and beyond.
Maybe a good place to start is,
when you were young,
when did you first realize that you had,
for lack of a better word, a gift?
That chess was something
that you were drawn to
and that you might be
able to stand out in?
- I think it sort of started
when I was nine and a half years old.
I started playing chess a little bit later
than many of the other kids
but I could notice that I
was sponging up information
in a way that they were not.
So like, I would play
tournaments with kids my age
pretty much every weekend.
And I could feel that I was
sort of improving week by week
and they were not.
And I realized that I had
just much more of a passion
and a drive to do this than they had.
So I think that's when I realized
that I could actually
be very good at this.
- And we have questions
coming in from Instagram.
Creation asked, who taught
you how to play chess?
How did you get introduced to the game?
And you mentioned it was relatively late
for someone who gets
to your level of chess.
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
So my father is quite a keen chess player.
He still enjoys playing chess a lot.
I would say he plays probably more chess
than I do to be honest.
He taught me and my sister
at a fairly young age.
But up till the age I was eight,
I really didn't know much at all.
But certainly without him
I would never have pursued
chess the way that I did.
- And we're having a ton of
questions you could imagine
from both experienced and
beginner chess players.
From Instagram, Clara is asking,
and I'm curious whether
you follow your own advice
but what is the most important thing
beginners should work on
to get better at chess?
And what were you working
on when you were a beginner?
- The thing is,
I don't think I was working
on anything in particular.
So we had some chess books
and magazines at home
so I would read them.
And there was this chess board we had.
So I would move the
pieces around sometimes
trying to imitate the games
that I had seen there.
But like after learning the very basics
and the rules from my father
it was more really a case of me
just trying out different things
and seeing what worked.
- You know, just as you
started playing other people
it was a bit of a rocket ship.
You just realized,
hey, there's things you're processing
that other people aren't,
you're getting better faster.
Were there times that you
were starting to plateau
and you had to do certain
things to get out of that,
to get to another level?
- There were certainly
times when I was younger
when yeah, I couldn't reach
that next level immediately.
And in hindsight,
obviously, that's something
that happens to everybody.
What I believed back then is
I had this sort of irrational confidence
that these are temporary setbacks.
Like the only reason
why I'm not progressing to the next level
is because I've had some bad luck
or in this particular tournament,
I wasn't able to show my best.
So I always believed that
I'm going to pull through
like next tournament, next game,
that's going to be mine.
And I think that mentality
more than anything else
is what allowed me to push through.
- And you know, I'm asking
you all of these questions
because people might not realize
I'm going to play a computerized
10-year-old version of you in a few days.
So I'm trying to get as
many tips as possible
to improve my chess game.
Here's the little card about (mumbles)
I'm going to be playing a
computerized 10-year-old Magnus.
I'm a reasonably serious amateur,
but I don't want to raise
anyone's expectations too much.
And Magnus, you probably
don't remember this,
I would like to say about
four or five years ago
we actually played each other at an event.
This was out here in Silicon Valley
where I was randomly selected from a hat.
I was one of four people to play you.
You were blindfolded.
I know you probably do this a lot
but it was very memorable for me,
and I was the last person standing.
So that was an exciting game.
- I was blindfolded (mumbles)
Is that the one?
Oh yeah, that I remember.
- I'm sure that game you
remember vividly in your head as,
(laughs loudly)
- Is that the game where I
forgot the position once.
- Yes, you do remember that game.
- Yeah.
- I briefly had an advantage.
I tell people that,
they don't believe.
- I know.
I think I blundered a rook or something.
'Cause I misremembered one
of the pawns as far as I can.
- Yeah, I was up one rook
at one point in the game.
And I tell this to
everyone who would listen,
I was at one point at an
advantage versus Magnus Carlsen.
And then I later tell him
that you were blindfolded
playing four other people.
And I think you even might've
had less time on your clock
than I did
but it was good for my self esteem.
I remember the moment when I saw that,
I'm like, he's doing
something really deep,
something really deep
because I think I just
take this (indistinct)
- No.
Surprisingly often when you
see a very strong player
appear to miss something of obvious,
they just missed it.
So that's what I keep telling everybody.
If it looks like your
opponent missed something
and you can't see why they didn't,
they probably did.
- That's actually a good life advice.
'Cause I think all the time we questioned
when there's something good happening.
You know, I think this relates,
actually, two of my kids
who are very such serious chess players,
this is Imran, and this is Azov,
who have been hanging out here.
Why don't y'all ask your questions.
They're actually missing
schoolwork for this.
- I'm not missing schoolwork.
- Okay
- Ask your question Azov,
then Imran you ask your question
and then I'll follow up.
What's your question, Azov?
- How do you beat all the people?
Okay, we're going to put
that in the (mumbles)
Oh, well, do you have a response to that?
How do you beat all the people?
- I don't know, to be honest.
And I don't beat all of them.
More talent, harder work, who knows?
- Talent and hard work.
You hear that, Azov?
- Okay.
- And Imran, what's your question.
- So like when you play blindfolded,
like you did against my dad,
like, is there any specific
way that you can memorize
the entire multiple boards in your head
or do you just do it?
- I think you can was sort of store them
in different parts of your brain.
So it's really only necessary
to have one board at a time,
but it's good to have some kind of face
or some kind of name
that you connect with,
with a certain board
so it's easier to distinguish
them from each other.
- Yeah, I mean, and
it's following actually
on both of their questions.
Famously and I think a lot of people,
and you've commented on "Queens Gambit."
A lot of people are really
getting into chess these days
but it does seem like
people who can perform
even close to your level
seem to have almost superhuman memories.
And it seems like you
do remember a lot of,
I mean, the fact that you
remembered that game versus me,
which is probably the least important game
you've ever played, does speak to that.
Is this something you've trained?
Is it only in chess
or do you have ability
to memorize scenarios
and visualize things
outside of chess as well?
- I would say that when I was young
I had a very, very good memory.
Now it's not so great anymore.
I would say at this point,
my memory is nothing exceptional.
I can remember patterns still,
I can remember the broad ideas
but I kind of remember everything.
I mean, let me tell you
that when I was young,
when I was a teenager, at
least in my early teens
like there is no way that I would be able
to only tell you that I
blundered rook at some point
because I displaced my pawn.
Back then I would've been able
to tell you the whole game
and details about it.
So I think now it's more
as you get older,
it's more about remembering
the broad lines of everything.
And I don't think I'm a
real exceptional there.
- And I think you're probably
being beat being humble
but it is fascinating that you're saying
that in some ways how
your brain tackles chess
and you've stayed at the top
of your game this entire time
but it has transitioned from being more
I guess you could say memory intensive
or computational intensive.
And now it's more almost
pattern recognition
is what I'm hearing.
And there's a question
from Instagram, Brian
it's related to this.
Does being a world champion stop you
from constantly trying
to improve your chess.
How do you get better?
Frankly, you're the best right now.
How do you push yourself to be better?
- Frankly, the emphasis
for me is on learning
and I don't know exactly how that is going
to make me a better chess player.
But I feel as though my
understanding of chess is evolving.
Looking at my games,
let's say five, six years ago,
I would say that my
understanding of the game
was considerably worse back then.
My results weren't necessarily worse.
But that is the fascinating part for me,
is that the game is evolving,
my understanding is evolving
and always learn learning something new.
And that really is
enough motivation for me
to keep on learning.
Whether it will make me
a better chess player,
I don't know.
'Cause sometimes in chess,
ignorance really can be bliss.
Sometimes if you have less knowledge
but knowledge that you are confident about
it can be better than just
having many, many ideas
many, many thoughts that
just makes you overthink.
- That was fascinating.
I mean, I'm really actually
blown away by the comment
where you say that four or five years ago
your understanding of the
game was much less deep
than it is today,
because four or five years ago
you were already World Chess Champion.
And you're saying that
you had a more superficial
understanding of the game.
So, I mean, it's fascinating
that there's still layers
that you are uncovering
even after becoming World Chess Champion.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And I think that happens
to all chess players
because the game is evolving
and it's the tragedy for everybody that
the more you know,
the worse you play
becomes at some point.
- And I'm curious,
as someone who is an amateur chess player
but I'm sure even many
experienced chess players.
What goes on in your head?
You know, in a lot of chess
someone like me, I might
recognize certain things
but I'm also doing a lot of the scenarios.
Well, if I do this,
they're going to do this.
If I do this, they're going to do this.
And I can go to down that tree
maybe three or four or five moves at best.
Are you doing that same type of thing
wait, if I do this, they do that
or is it something else?
- Oh, it can be.
But I think, since I'm
much more experienced
I would use my long-term memory
more than my short term.
But clearly, sometimes
you do have to calculate
and then it's, as you say, no deeper than,
yeah, if I do this, you
will have to do this
and then I'll do that and so on.
And then there may be two or
three options on each move.
So the tree of variation
sort of becomes broader and messier.
But at the end of the day
you can't escape sort of
calculation by brute force
no matter how much you want to play
on intuition and strategy
rather than tactics
- I can imagine.
And we have a question here
from Facebook, Margo McGinnis
who actually helped coordinate
the first time we played
and now this time that
I'm going to be playing
versus the digital you.
This is Margo's question.
What was your most memorable
or nerve-racking match?
And I'll add to this,
how do you deal with stress?
Do you get nervous during matches?
- Yeah, I would certainly say
the first World Championship
match that I had in 2013,
at the start, I was so nervous
that I dropped one of my
pieces on the first move,
which is so fascinating
because even at that point
I was the highest rated
player in the world
and I was very experienced.
But the task of playing
the World Championship
was so daunting to me
that for the first four games
or yeah, three or four games,
I was still unbelievably nervous
'cause it was something that
was absolutely new to me.
- And how do you deal with that?
Do you just say, breathe,
one move at a time kind of thing?
- I don't know how to deal
with it, to be honest.
So the way that I dealt with it was
I played one good game
and then my confidence was back
and I didn't have a care in the world.
Very often people search for like
do I have any method or
deeper meaning to what I do
but what I explained at the beginning was,
my method was mainly trial and error.
And it still is to some extent.
That I find out what
works for me at some point
simply by experiencing it,
not necessarily by good planning.
- And do you ever while you're
in the middle of the game
(mumbles)
We always be, oh, I can't
believe I made that move.
Like that was a (indistinct)
How often does that happen to you?
That you're like, oh my god,
that was a careless mistake,
or I can't believe I did that
- Every single game.
(laughs loudly)
Yeah, I can't remember a single one
where I haven't had those thoughts.
Like sometimes there would
be a massive blunder,
another time it will be
an unavoidable inaccuracy.
But every time it's like,
you've played chess your whole life
and still you can't figure this out.
Yeah, it's the same.
- And it sounds like,
to your earlier comment about that moment
which I will never stop bragging about
where I had an advantage
versus you playing blindfolded
against four other people.
Is what you said earlier,
I mean, you probably hide it well
because now what you
know is to be a mistake
or you miss something,
most other people will probably
see it as a deep insight.
Something that it probably scares them.
- Yeah, normally it's just a mess up.
That's what it is.
- You know, there's a lot
of questions coming in
about chess and your life.
You know, I guess this is a question.
YouTube Ghost Tommy, how's
chess affected your life?
Has it improved you?
And I'll extend that question
of how are you viewing chess
and your life going forward?
And you've achieved the
top of your game literally
at a very, very young age.
You're still very, very young.
What do you see as the future?
Do you feel, you know,
defending your title?
(mumbles)
You're constantly on your game
or is it really just the love of the game
and what else is going
on outside of chess?
- No, really I just want to learn
and playing both
tournaments and casual games
still give me satisfaction and joy.
So for the moment,
I haven't really thought too
much about anything else.
Whatever titles maybe out there
that's not the main
motivation at this point.
In that case, I feel like
it's just calm with me.
It's about learning and
having fun, to be honest.
- It's good to hear that.
I mean, it's amazing
when you even said that
how much more you've learned
about the game of chess
over the last four or five years
when you were already
at the top of your game.
It really does sound like
there's this opportunity,
there's a journey.
There's a beauty in the
game that never gets old.
And related to that,
there's a question here from
Facebook, Cynthia Hurtado,
and this is a good question,
something I've always wondered.
What do you think about
the rise of chess engines
and the digital age of chess?
How has that changed the game?
How has that changed your thinking?
Is it different to play
against a supercomputer
versus a great human player?
- Frankly, I don't play
a lot against computers.
Like basically the only time
that I play against computer opponents
is when I play my own app.
And computers have changed dramatically
the way that we prepare for games.
Not necessarily for the better
because it's left sort of
less scope for creativity.
I think computers though
have made the game
much more accessible for casual fans
because now you can sort of see,
you can see a score
and they can also aid in
giving you instant feedback
when you play your games.
So I guess overall,
they've certainly been a positive
but in terms of how I view chess engines,
I view them as more of a,
for me, a necessary
evil than a good thing.
To me, it would be,
yeah, the game would
be just as interesting
without a computer analysis.
- And you know, you said
a really interesting thing
that I've heard great chess players say,
you know, the creativity of the game,
the beauty of the game.
And I definitely have glimpses of that
when I sometimes play.
But double-click on that a little bit.
What do you mean where it says,
when you play against human versus human,
there's maybe a little
more space for creativity?
What does that mean?
- It just means that humans
they have emotions,
they have actual thoughts.
It's sort of a game of both
some emotion and ideas.
And with computers,
it just becomes technique basically.
It's only about technique
and that's why I find it in
general, less interesting
- Is that part of your game?
I mean, I find it fascinating.
You know, chess famously
was built off of a metaphor
for real warfare in the real
world, an ancient warfare.
And ancient warfare we all know
isn't just who is the
best tactical fighter.
There's psychology, there's
tricks, there's faints.
How much of that is a game
at the very highest level?
I do imagine these people who
are playing with each other
they're thinking way down the road,
they can think about the positions,
they can think about all these things.
How much is it playing with
the other person's emotions
or tricking them
or making them not see something,
kind of do a faint of
hands, things like that?
- The faster the games,
the more there's room
for all sorts of trickery
that to my mind makes the
game more interesting.
Again, as you have more and more time,
it becomes more technical.
But certainly at shorter time controls,
there is a lot of
psychology involved in it.
There's much more room
to sort of adjust your strategy
according to your opponents.
- I think a lot of people
have watched "Queens Gambit."
I've seen on social media
you've commented on
"Queens Gambit" a good bit.
I mean, I am curious in this forum,
what are your thoughts about it?
And do you think it was pretty realistic
to the game of chess?
The main character in "Queens Gambit"
she famously is kind
of an intuitive player
versus a kind of a computational.
I'm sure she's doing some of that too
or at least the character would.
Well, what are your thoughts about it
and what's it done to the game of chess?
- Well, I think the only
reason she can be intuitive
is that she studied very, very hard.
One of the things
I love to see about the series,
is that she studies so hard
and she has such great
respect for the game.
Also, I feel like they did
the chess pretty well there.
The fragments from games
were very realistic
and sometimes beautiful as well.
When it comes to the atmosphere
around the tournaments and so on,
I guess some things are fictionalized.
But overall, I was very happy with it
and hopefully people will watch it
and they will not be scared,
but rather encouraged to play chess.
- And you know, there's so many questions.
I know we're running low on time
but I'll ask a few more of these,
really around how do you cope with
especially in the early days
when maybe you were getting
beaten every now and then.
How did you deal with that failure
and how do you manage your own emotions?
I mean, are there times that you get
where you're feeling either
bad about yourself or angry
or you're frustrated
with a given opponent?
- I have to say that when I was young
and I guess I lost a
lot more than I do now,
I didn't care so much about losses
'cause I didn't expect
to win all the time.
As I said, it was like,
I wanted to play stronger players
that I could learn the most.
It was not about winning.
I just wanted to sort of
get to the next level,
that I could match up with
stronger and stronger opponents
and then beat them eventually.
In recent years
when I've become used to being
at the top most of the time,
yeah, now losing hurts.
I'm not gonna lie there, like every time.
And it's not even losing.
Like I might be equally
upset after a game that I won
as a game that I lost
if I feel like I did something,
I made a mistake that I
could easily have avoided
or I didn't act professionally enough
in the way that I executed the game.
So yeah, 20 years of playing
chess has not prevented me
from having sort of emotional reactions
to things that happen at the chess board.
- You know, one of the
things that I think is hard
when people have been so
successful for so long,
do you sometimes model in your mind,
what if five years, 10 years in the future
the next Magnus Carlsen comes
and is able to beat me?
Is that something that you think about?
How do you think that would
affect you if that happened?
- I remember I was asked this question,
I think 11 years ago.
And at that point it upset me
because they worded the question
as what are you going to do
when that next one comes along?
And I said very clear that, in my mind
this was a question of if.
And also that I thought
I have so many years
till that will be a real thing.
I think I'm realistic
enough though at this point
to realize that I'm not going to be able
to be at the highest level forever.
If I do want to keep on playing
chess at the highest level,
then at some point I'm
going to start regressing.
But for the moment,
I'm thinking like
I should still should
still be in my prime,
and that's what I should strive towards.
- Yeah, no, I definitely phrased it as if.
I'm not assuming that anyone is gonna,
(indistinct)
- No, obviously the most
likely scenario is that
somebody is going to surpass me,
I wouldn't say sooner rather than later,
but in the not too distant future.
But I'm gonna try
and hold on as long as I can.
- When we think about the
arc of the game of chess,
how it's evolved,
do you think that the
competition is only going higher
and higher and higher over time,
that people are understanding the game
at deeper and deeper levels?
Or do you think some of the
old greats from 50 years ago
or 60 years ago, or even 100 years ago
would actually still be great today?
- I think it's a bit of both.
The game is certainly evolving
especially with the computers.
It has made us reevaluate
a lot of the truth that
we held to be self-evident
once upon a time.
But I also do feel,
and this is gonna make me
sound a lot older than I am.
But I do feel that some
of the youngsters today
they're not too good at the basics.
Like, I feel like the generation
that I'm a part of and
the generation before
maybe understood the
fundamentals of the game
a little bit better
than the kids do today.
And I think that's partly
a result of growing up with a computer
rather than a board.
- It's fascinating.
'Cause I'm sure the youngsters
that you're talking about
are still quite good at chess.
But you're saying,
- Obviously yes.
- even some of these folks,
and when you say the basics
what do you mean by that?
Like what types of things
do you think they have maybe some gaps in?
- I think some gaps in just
general positional
understanding of the game.
Like studying the classic games
I think has clear value.
Like far from everything
that you learn from back then
is still true today.
But I don't think you can develop
a broad enough understanding
of the game to be the best
by only training with a computer.
- It's fascinating.
Yes, you do sound older than you are.
How old are you exactly?
(mumbles)
- Yeah, I just turned 30 last November.
What I will say though,
I think I'm lucky
to be in sort of a
hybrid generation there.
I sort of started playing chess
before the computers were
absolutely everywhere.
Like I actually went
to a school with books
and notebooks and so on
before everything became
computerized and so on.
And I think it's sort of a good position
to be in that sort of a hybrid
that you have a good
knowledge of computers
but that you can also sort of relate
to the old way the game was played.
- And maybe in the time we have left,
you know, one question that
I'm sure a lot of people,
and people are asking this question,
what other subjects are you
interested in, Math or physics?
There's sometimes
connection between chess.
But I am curious
have you ever done the thought exercise?
If you weren't World Chess Champion
or if you didn't have this chess life,
in that alternate reality
what would Magnus Carlsen be doing?
- Yeah, I've been asked
it many times for sure.
Never had a good answer,
probably still don't.
One thing that I will say though
is that I have massive respect
for people in almost any field.
And I think there are lots
even fairly bright people
who think that somebody like me
could become good at something
else with very little effort.
But I really don't think so.
I think most of all, I'm somebody who
evidently, I have some talent for chess,
but most of all,
I've spent a lot of time working on it
and thinking about it.
And I think that I'm not necessarily
the fastest at anything.
I need some time.
and then I just keep learning.
But to think of something else,
no, I don't think like there's anything
that I could imagine I would
be anywhere equally as good at.
In that case
I would have to spend
nearly all my time on it
as I have with chess.
- Well, it does seem like the mindset
that you've taken to chess.
There's probably things your mind can do
that would be very useful in other fields
even if we limit ourselves to games.
Do you play other games?
You know, famously a lot
of elite athletes who,
you know, Michael Jordan tried golf,
LeBron James, I recently
read an article of like
he could have been a football player.
Have you thought,
well, there's other games
I could have played,
Go or Mahjong or something else.
Have you ever tried these things
or do you even play other
games outside of chess?
- The thing is for something like Go,
I feel like chess might
almost be (mumbles)
Having spent a lot of time in chess
might almost be a disadvantage
because I think that the
mindset there is very different.
And for a chess player,
Go seems very, very
abstract compared to chess.
I wouldn't say I'm great at anything else.
I mean, I've tried games.
Like I play poker with
my friends occasionally
without being particularly great at it.
I've tried, Shogi, Go briefly
without excelling at any of those things.
So I really wouldn't know.
- I just imagined playing poker
or any other game against you.
And I do think you have
an intimidation factor
which would play to your strengths
- It goes away very quickly.
(laughs loudly)
- Well, I know we're out of time.
I mean, first of all, thank you so much.
I look forward to playing
the robot version of you,
which I'm pretty sure will crush me,
but I'm going to practice
with my co-conspirators
that you met earlier.
My older is,
he's pretty decent.
He's I think just gotten better than me.
He gives me my run for the money.
But Magnus, thank you so much.
Yeah, thank you so much.
Obviously, fascinating
what you've been able
to accomplish in chess.
But I think even more,
chess as a metaphor for
life is very powerful
and what you've been
able to do in the game.
And just understanding
a little bit of how you
think about chess and life
I think has a lot of insights
that go well beyond chess.
So thank you so much for joining us today.
- Thank you so much for having me
and all the best to all of
you in this difficult time.
- Great, thank you so much Magnus.
So thanks everyone for
joining today's Homeroom.
I could have talked to
Magnus for a few more hours.
I feel like we've got glimpses
into what goes on in his mind
both intellectually and emotionally.
And you know, some of the takeaways,
he's a human being just
like the rest of us.
But it would be fun to be
able to see a chess board
the way that he sees a chess board.
But you can see a 10-year-old
robot version of Magnus,
crushing me likely in chess.
It's all about setting
expectations in the right place.
We're going to have a live
event as the card had shown
in a couple of days.
But thank you all for joining us.
It's gonna be @ChampionsChessTour.com.
And I'm definitely part
of the entertainment
more than the serious competition.
Well, I do play a little bit.
As Magnus said, it's now documented.
He remembers the game,
which I find incredibly flattering,
but he also admitted that
I briefly had a moment
when he forgot something
because he was playing for
other people simultaneously
with a blindfold on.
But with that, thanks so much
for coming to today's Homeroom
and I will see you all next week, I think.
See you then.
(bouncy music)